[Music]
the cool thing about time series data is
it is coming from places where we don't
normally think of data it's kind of this
new era that's happening this isn't web
this isn't this is in terms of banking
applications but we really see it
emerging in many places this is where in
New York this is financial tic data but
it's also when we think of system
monitoring we have our machines during
talking with massive amounts of time
series data a lot of this actually also
comes from old areas you know if you
think about transportation logistics if
you track every location of a car or
container and you want to make planning
decisions who want to look how your
assets are moving this is again time
series data we see this in an AI and
industrial machines and there's a whole
area called predictive maintenance and
of course with things like web and event
so we have this question of that time
series data seems to be emerging
everywhere the interesting thing we
found is when we started talking to
people about our time series database in
the beginning there was actually a lot
of confusion of what that actually means
because actually if you look at a lot of
the no sequel time series databases on
the market right now they actually all
mean a very specific thing that's much
more narrower than the problem time
series data in general so let me spend a
minute just talking about what we mean
and if you think kind of abstractly
about something like IOT which is a
bunch of devices generating a lot of
data kind of there's some unique
characteristics of these data streams
one is that they're putting out these
amounts of data if you look here I'm
trying to show this illustration where
different sensors or different sensor
types of putting out the streams of data
and particular data is generally getting
written too late as time it's it's very
insert heavy workload and we'll come
back to why that's important in a minute
now if you look at a lot of time series
databases they have a very specific way
of storing this and if you ask them they
would say I have let's say they'll say I
have 200 time series and what they mean
by that is if they would define a time
series as a particular metric like a CPU
associated with a set of tags a unique
set of tags so here if you look at this
picture I have a bunch of times I have a
bunch of metrics and then I have a bunch
of common
and you might look at this and say I
about ten times series here and if you
think about that way the number of time
series is actually the combinatorial
growth growth comma toriel with the
number of unique tags you have now of
course this is the only way to store it
and going back to this what happens with
a lot of people build very efficient
architecture where they store these
column formats and you know that's the
only type of analysis they could
efficiently do but in many cases you
know just have these narrow rows you
have a lot of fields together and so my
example here is imagine you're doing
cold chain monitoring you have a bunch
of container ships and it's great if you
could store our temperature humidity and
CPU average but it's also important that
you understand the relationships because
for example if your temperature Peaks is
this because you're in fact refrigerated
car is no longer working or is it
because for some reason you have a bug
and your CPU is locked at 100 and all
you're doing is measuring the radiant
temperature of your CPU so this
relationships are important and again
it's something to think about when we
design time series databases the other
thing is a lot of times we additionally
have additional measurement or metadata
so for example it's important to know
that we have containers but often we
want to know what's inside those
containers and this is the traditional
relational model of time series data
it's very important that we know that
for example our frozen food is not being
refrigerated when my electronics are
probably find out that and so what we
want to think about is how do we build a
time series database that could solve
all of these not just single metrics but
also support a rich relational model
because in many cases that's what people
were actually the richer types of
questions they want to ask we're related
to this today a lot of times would have
people as they store their time series
data in one database and their
relational data in another database and
they kind of pump the problem up the
application layer now this is great for
the employment of application developers
but if you think about the main purpose
of the database is the ease with data
management it doesn't really help you
that much there and sometimes when the
analyst wants to ask a new question it
means that they need to get the
engineers you know in an engineering
sprint three months from now to add this
to a sprint so they could now ask a new
type of query that joins across these
two databases
and so you might say well is this
necessary why don't people just use
relational databases and in fact if you
ask a bunch of people what they're using
what we found this is a survey by
percona last year more than two thirds
said they were using a no sequel
database and so the question we had is
if this inhibited a lot of this type of
analysis which you might want to do
why so much now no sequel that is why
not use a simple relational database so
one of the things is if you try to fire
up you I asked about another great
database like Postgres see if you try to
fire up standard Postgres trying to
store all this data all this time series
data you know in a Postgres table what
you'll see is things start looking well
this is inserts per second this is doing
inserts row by row clearly and I'll show
you it's a lot more efficient if you do
batches of inserts but row by row things
look happy at at first but once the
database gets a little big things kind
of go off a cliff right and we see this
big plunge large variance and sometimes
you're getting on the order of a few
hundred inserts per second what's
happening is you're trying to index this
data your indexes are not all staying in
memory and so now when you're inserting
a piece of data into your database
basically you need to maintain a
separate B tree for each of these
dimensions and then when you insert it
need to update that B tree which means a
lot of swapping back and forth to disk
and that's why we see this big
performance so memories memories good
disk is bad not so surprising but
ultimately the nature of time series
data was leave a lot of it and so
clearly we want to exceed that be able
to exceed the capacity of the entire
database fully in memory so you could
say why don't we just use no sequel
that's what a lot of people have seemed
to do and generally no single databases
have turned to these data structures are
called log structured merge trees which
have made inserts quicker because they
don't actually always store a global
sorted order over disks they keep these
independent what they call in the
independent sorted sequences and then
write them to disk as a batch then in
the background they slowly merge that
together now this is and in fact this is
the prototype
most know sequel databases and so this
actually leads to higher insert rates
but the problem is it often leads to
very high in memory investing so the
reason a lot of these things talk about
the number of time series is they
basically will start keeping these
separate data structures for each of
these unique time series and so if the
number of times just grows is like
combinatorial as the combination between
all these different unique sets of tags
these things will if you have a million
different device ID is a thousand
locations and ten different data types
this is already 10 billion separate time
series and this databases can't handle
that what kind of limits and how you can
do and they also have another
limitations like no joins and the whole
loss of lava sequel at ecosystem so we
said I have asking this question is
there a better way to build this and
that's what we set out to do with time
series time scale DB which is a scalable
time series database that provides full
sequel in a high level we provide three
goals and the first is that we really
provide full sequel so windowing sub
query CT ease joins anything you have in
sequel you can basically do in time in
time scale on top of that we add a bunch
of time oriented features and this
allows you to then have one database
that basically stores both your
relational data and your time series
data so you could move all these joints
into the database and but the last
interesting thing is that we expose the
abstraction of what looks like a single
table and what that means is that if you
have any existing tool that could speak
to Postgres this is anywhere from like
an ORM like ruby to something very
enterprising like tableau or microsoft
power bi it will just work with time
scale out of the box the second thing
and I'll talk about this little more is
it supports high write rates and a bunch
of time oriented optimizations to the
extent that on a single node we have
people running at a hundreds of billions
of rows per node and maintain that high
high insert performance and the last
thing which was pretty important for us
is that we kind of stand on the
shoulders of giants which is Postgres
that we've been someone careful to keep
the lowest level of storage native to
Postgres and so effectively inherent
that inherit reliability that Postgres
has developed over the last 20 years
okay so the big question is how do we
take an existing database like Postgres
and make it scalable for time series
data and the key insight is that time
series workloads are actually a
different problem than traditional OLTP
workloads in particular if you look at
these traditional transactional
workloads you primarily have updates you
know you have a Bank of America let's
say us fifty million customers that data
that number of customers is not that big
but often you go in and you like well
exchange money between account so it
might be thought of us an update to one
account and it change to another account
in one form of transactions primary
updates the rights are randomly
distributed
you're touching random user IDs and you
often have these transactions to
multiple primary keys when in time
series we typically have these inserts
right and these inserts are typically
this append-only workload are typically
to the recent time interval and these
rights are typically assessed with this
with timestamp and some other data but
not randomly distributed not kind of
transactions to multiple and so what
we'll see is we can take advantage of
the fact that it's a very append-only or
pend heavy workload so we look back or
picture one of the key ways that time
scale is architected that if you think
about this is your data model as these
are in kind of new sensor readings or
new financial tic data coming in then we
provide the abstraction of what we call
as a hyper table and to the outside
world this hyper table looks like a
single table but under the covers it is
actually partitioned in one or more ways
the first thing is by time you could
build a bunch of partitions and these
time intervals could be specified
manually like hourly or minute Li or
daily or the system the database also
has a way to dynamically adjust these
intervals based on the data volumes to
provide the good result and just to give
you a foreshadowing some people will say
well don't I do partitioning already in
something like Postgres 10 or other
databases
I'll show you we're talking about at
performance where the database will
automatically generate a new partition
even every several minutes and we'll be
dealing with tens of thousands of these
partitions at on any single node so it's
very different from like traditional
manual partitioning
you would have in a database the second
thing is you could do this in terms of
some space we're often commonly with Lou
in oval or hash partitioning in space a
common thing is if you have many
different devices you want to separate
them again to get these to the good size
to chunks and we call these chunks what
they are stored at the lowest level is
actually just an internal table inside
Postgres but from the outside world the
user will only see this hyper table so
your inserts and your queries and your
constraints and your triggers and your
up certs and anything else you deal with
the database will actually all be done
by the hyper table you won't actually be
dealing with chunks at all but under the
covers what this hyper table is going to
do is figure out or even schema
management alter schema will all be in
terms of the hyper table under the
covers it's going to be figure out how
to properly route and search the right
chunk how to do efficient queries over
which precise small set of chunks that
wants to touch how do I map proper
constraints this disjoint set of chunks
how do I properly do up certs and so
forth and if you look at visually what
will happen is as more data gets gets
come in these chunks will naturally be
created and as a new time intervals
appear the database is going to
naturally dynamically create these more
chunks possibly sized adaptively and and
map the new data against them and as an
example of why that's important and why
kind of manual partitioning doesn't work
for example a user thing you know we
inserted 500 billion rows into what
looks like a single table on a single
node and basically we maintain the type
of performance so here they're getting
400,000 inserts per second at 500
billion rows and interestingly at the
end basically the database was
dynamically creating the set of chunks
every five minutes and had about 50,000
chunks internally so this is really
beyond what you're going to see in any
other database that we know about let me
talk about why you get some nice chunk
why you get some of this benefits the
first big idea here and how we do this
adaptive sizing and what people think
when they manually tune it is that we
want to make chunks
right-sized what that means is that the
recent chunks in recent in time
basically all very naturally fit in
memory and because indexing is all local
to the chunks what that means is these
indexes themselves are small and so
whatever you need to even update the
index when you insert new data it's
again updating this very small index
that's naturally maintained in memory
and so without kind of redoing this
entire database and losing any of their
other functionality we can naturally get
this type of behavior but precisely
because the nature of time-series
workloads the Vedas are insert heavy for
recent time intervals reven updates
randomly distributed over all of your
data
the second thing this leads to which
again is very important in many times
serious applications is efficient
retention policies so for example a
thing that's somewhat common is I'm only
gonna keep raw data for let's say a week
or a month and then I'm going to keep
aggregates for long periods of time and
typically in a single table this would
actually involve a delete query that
would end up remove individual rows from
a table this would cause fragmentation
that itself would be slow and then also
vacuuming to basically defrag it would
also be slow because of these type of
chunks you can set data retention
policies or run efficient commands they
basically say drop the chunks whose all
of whose data is older than this period
and that's basically just deleting a
file on disk as opposed to removing
individual rows as part of a table and
the interesting thing about this
chunking design is that it's kind of the
same basic architecture for queries as
we have for single node and as we are as
we release next year for the clustered
version in particular one other thing
that it also allows us to even on a
single node to scale up by adding many
disks and you could do this either
through raid we're also in Postgres
through table spaces where you could
have many table spaces on a single table
on a single hyper table which we move
from a Postgres usually a tablespace
effective is a mount point so you have
to map usually a table to a single mount
point on your filesystem right but here
we could have one hyper table is just an
abstraction over many tables and so as
your basic elastically adding
which is particularly powerful in a
cloud environment where you can network
attach these disks you could basically
these new time intervals which which get
created get load bounced all over all
the disks that you have subsequently
added there's leads to both faster
inserts and also allows you to paralyze
queries over these different disks the
second thing is that kind of a technique
under development is that this is the
same kind of sharding technique in
chunking technique that also takes us to
distributed environments where now grab
these shards being on a single machine
or across many disks they're actually on
many servers as well because already our
query planner is actually doing
transactions across touching many of
these chunks at the same time what this
will allow you to do is insert a query
to any server as well as distribute kree
optimizations like pushing down limits
and aggregations and various other
things so the thing this allows us to do
is not just on how it maintains its high
insert rate but also leads us to do
various chunk aware creations
particularly where we have kind of
semantic knowledge of time which a
normal database doesn't think about one
thing this allows to do is kind of very
aggressive constraint exclusion so for
example given these large numbers of
chunks and again you have 50,000 chunks
naively what's something like Postgres
will do is when you have they allow this
thing called table inheritance when you
query the parent it's actually going to
run the same query against all the
children that's okay if you have ten ten
children it's a very different thing you
have 50,000 children right but our the
way we build this allows us to given
kind of tie into the grade planner to
given it particularly query we can look
at this calculate the constraints
recognize that this interval only covers
a few chunks and then only be able to
push down the query to those chunks
similarly we could push down to a
particular device where here it selected
a particular device and space
partitioning or kind of push gram slice
across time and or or sapote higher
number of dimensions as well now the
interesting question is this is again
thinking about time has allowed us to
certain optimizations so for example let
me know the difference between these two
queries
yeah well once is now the other one
seems to static this unfortunately
Postgres can't handle well and the
reason being is because this type of
function is done in the this function is
not if you do prepared statements it's
not going to execute until execution and
the planner actually works at prepared
statements this is even trickier if you
do lose a time stamp even if this wasn't
now and was a fixed time it might not
know if you've done that a prepared time
if the system time has changed between
when the the query was plant and
prepared and was actually executed so we
do this in sequel for in Postgres for
example this again will give up on
constraint exclusion and will touch all
the queries but again because we
optimize for time we move a lot of is
logic from the planner into actually our
execution engine and then we'll properly
do aggressive constraint exclusion
wherever we can
again there's various things that things
that we do because we are focused on
time series analysis that Postgres
natively won't so second thing you'd ask
that seems great it has some scale is
this just about time and I touched about
some of these before
which is that the one thing this allows
you to do is kind of operationally this
moves from this world where you have a
separate relational database and a new
steagle database to something where
you're running one Postgres instance and
joining between these two types of data
another thing that we kind of add is as
again we're focusing on time series
analysis we kind of add additional
analytics so this is the one a blog post
that one of our interns wrote last
summer and actually this is a cool
intern project in their first couple
weeks she wrote this learned sequel to
do it and then it became kind of went
number one in hacker news I think it was
read a hundred thousand times but what
her now since was doing of course it was
about cryptocurrency because that's what
hacker news cares about but what she was
doing was she was taking advantage a lot
of these functions that we added or
really UDF's that we added about time
series analysis that you don't find in
traditional post press and as we're
going on we're adding kind of more and
more the type of analysis the nice other
thing about time scale is because it is
implemented as a Postgres extension it
actually plays well with other Postgres
extensions so a very fairly common type
of an
elseis is through geospatial temporal
analysis that is let's actually look
about both geospatial analysis then
coupled with time so this is actually a
type of query that is very similar to
what of our kind of financial customers
use that you can take a region for
example this is this is using the post
GIS extension and do this kind of fancy
geometries and polygons or whatever but
also think about the time component rest
of you as well and yet do all this
constraint exclusion across these chunks
you don't get in just one big table
there's thing about a 10x improvement
when they were able to go from this
single table model this heavily chunked
model and the last thing you get and
kind of allude to this already is things
like data retention policies and
aggregates that you could have again
have one hyper table with raw data you
might set a retention policy like a week
another hyper table with let's say
15-minute a grits with different
retention policies and a key important
thing to is the way you actually do this
is you take advantage of the fact that
we have really built in support for up
sirs
so up search for who who aren't familiar
is insert the row if it's new otherwise
you could update an existing row and
what this allows you to do is kind of be
a little sloppy with late data one of
the problems with doing these aggregates
is what happens if I finish let's say
five minute interval I computer an
aggregate and then a piece of data comes
in late right it goes back and touches
that old five minute interval that I
already computed the aggregate for what
you kind of want to do is compute this
windowed form where were you recompute
things that have already been touched
but the ability up certs means that
you're not having spurious records in
your database again something like
sessional Postgres table inheritance
doesn't do this correctly it can't
actually handle this constraints
correctly this is awesome that we've
engineered fairly carefully to work in
our hyper table model and the kind of
honor I allude to this already is that
because again our hyper table it just
looks like standard tables if you use
any one of these existing tools that
will just work out of the box you're
fauna was perhaps a nice addition just
two weeks ago launch date Postgres
sticks to a connector now I do want to
actually obviously mention a little bit
about performance so you saw some of
this graph before and this was still
doing these single row inserts which
anyway who's running a database could
tell you is not the fastest way to build
one but the nice thing is post race goes
off the cliff and because of this
chunking architecture kind of primal
skills it maintains is very consistent
performance now if you take that a
little bit further by the way this is
about 250 million rows and you'll see
that I include metrics per second
because if you come from the time series
database no sequel time series database
world sometimes you report the number of
individual metrics you insert per second
not the number of rows and so we're kind
of these are ten ten columns per row now
if you extend this to larger batch sizes
so here's the database going good
billion rows Postgres is again really
good when everything fits in memory and
then goes off this clip right we're in
time scale kind of maintains is pretty
consistent performance until you
basically see this 20x performance gap
between you know using time scale or or
natively using Postgres or something on
the order of of a million or we've had
people you know it depends a lot on the
hardware this is a kind of a standard
box and azure what you might normally
use now it's not just insert side
there's a lot of improvements on the
query sides as well anything between
kind of simple that should be table skin
simple table scans I don't know exactly
what happened there I'm the being rough
of the same or some 20% faster group
eyes being something like 2x faster or
very common thing in time series data
which we called up here time oriented
group eyes would be something like give
me the average metric every five minutes
ordered by time descending you know
limit whatever limit limit a week and
again the output of that aggregate over
five minutes is a function so taut so
Postgres doesn't know how to order
natively it's used to compute a lot all
of it
before it actually computes the ordering
and limits when because time scale has a
semantic knowledge of what these that
these functions are operating on time
and what they mean well you do a lot
more efficient thing to get some kind of
ridiculous you know 10,000 times faster
the native Postgres was
these are kind of the data retention
policies being as well now some of you
might ask we're very familiar with post
crest could say what about Postgres ten
has in Postgres ten really improved the
thing with with declarative partitioning
Postgres ten did indeed make things
somewhat better if you do batch inserts
the red line is time scale the blue line
is PG ten or if you're trying to go back
to single rope inserts Postgres ten
didn't really solve the problem now the
main difference is again in a
traditional database you often will
create a partition per day or per month
you're not trying to think about it how
do I make my system efficient for
handling fifty thousand partitions on a
single node the other question you might
ask is what about no sequel and again
turns out that Postgres in its own
phases engineered pretty robustly again
some of these no sequel databases so
again we're seeing about a 10x
performance improvements against
Cassandra and similarly a whole bunch of
speed ups in terms of queries as well
anything from simple fans being two to
40 times faster - again these time order
group eyes being close to 2,000 times
faster last point is very common query
in IOT it's something like tell me the
last record you have from every unique
device in your in your system we're
pretty common and again the nice thing
of interesting thing about that is we've
had people who actually replaced a small
cluster of Cassandra nodes with a single
instance of crime scale using standards
replication for a check now the one
questions I talk about all this
partitioning and fancy stuff how
difficult is that to actually deploy and
I think my point is you know our goal is
to be very opinionated databases we
don't want people to be manually
thinking about how they set up all this
we just want them to give them what
looks like a table and to have
everything magically happen under the
covers so basically if you have time
Sue's data which you store in a
traditional Postgres database your
migration processes the following you
create a table or you can do create
table data like your other table you run
this one magic command
which says create this hyper table
convert this table into this hyper table
talking about time here is the is the
endure interval column e you could do a
little fence if you want but it's the
simplest version and there you've now
migrated your table into a hyper table
so if people would like to more learn
more or download check it out we are
open source Apache - you can download it
from github and I would like to end this
by saying we are actually located 70
blocks south of here right near Grand
Central and we are hiring a whole bunch
of different areas of core database
engineers R&D support engineers or if
there's not something on the board that
you don't see but you might be
interested and come talk to me otherwise
questions
yeah so questions he'll be benchmarked
against KTB we haven't partly our lack
of kV licensing possibly terms of use
but I think the big thing we find and we
talked about the financial firms KTB is
super optimized for in-memory really
keeping things in l2 relatively small
datasets column-oriented I imagine I'm
very simple called roll-ups they are
faster but what they lack is basically
sequel and though we talk to a lot of
people the choice is not easy versus us
in terms of how fast can you roll up a
single take Street it's more I have
these full set of tools that I can't
have my organization use because there's
only five people right
yes so I mean what you're seeing as
sequel is making this big resurgence
across a whole variety of things one
place of it's happened has been for
streaming systems so a cockpit just
announced a sequel if you look at the
big growth and spark streaming in spark
sequel I think the big difference is
they're largely offering on the window
in context the idea people on the stream
crop circle is need to find a window
function you shoot data through it and
every you know you compute admits you
admit them to something else you often
use that word you know in place
real-time roll ups or use that for
things like alerting we often sees us
used in a different scenario which is
that people are trying to build so much
operationalize or kind of data warehouse
or analytical workloads some of this
could be streaming people have used this
but for that type of scenario but the
big thing is they want to touch
historical data and they where they want
to power dashboards where you want to
take a grits over different periods or
you have a real-time view and sometimes
want to go back in time and look for a
date allowed to ad-hoc queries we see
these two things as both important
things in the market and we kind of
people people have actually use it's
very complementary to the query relation
where those time scale work with other
post based extensions such as situs or
hll do you know actually I could ask you
the same I so I imagine that time scale
absolutely works with many Postgres
extensions I said post GIS what I don't
know is is cite us we have not tested it
yet you're also welcome to do the same I
think we both I think the question is
how I know
unlike many post cross extensions you
both integrate pretty deeply and take
over the query planner so it effectively
I think it means more how we trample at
each other's feet but um we should do
that I will Pete the question I
apologize for forgetting that he
answered before was asking about how
does this compare to streaming to very
sequel that's an emerging upstream
processing and the previous question was
how does time scale compared to K 2 K dB
so I have a question around the metadata
so when you're inserting into tables
where you really don't have any
assumptions about the structure of the
metadata and you in essence have like
multiple time series what are your
thoughts around that yeah so it's
interesting that you I mean the the
phrasing again you have multiple time
series I think is a little bit from a
particular particular world what we find
is that as something that builds on
Postgres tree support kind of all the
capabilities of Postgres and so what
that means is we have full kind of JSON
and JSON B support as well as well as
gin and nixing and all the indexing you
get on JSON as well
and so we have people use us in a
variety of ways one is they store us
kind of a narrow form one is they stored
us in wide form denormalized and wide
and again it depends a little on your
data model some they actually have
separate metadata tables that they will
join against the more time series tables
sometimes they actually store their
metadata if it's very sparse as JSON
objects as JSON blobs inside the
database and so again the interesting
thing is the one thing that no sequel
database
have done is basically taught post press
in my sequel if they need to add better
support for JSON and they've done and
now they actually often provide a lot
better support for even indexing and
validation on JSON then maybe the no
seal databases this is work with other
databases specifically Oracle and/or
Sybase well so the question was does it
work with database like Oracle and cytus
so sign us Sybase oh Sybase sorry so
time skill itself is an extension built
on Postgres it's actually quite
integrated into Postgres so time scale
needs to be deployed with Postgres
Postgres itself has a fairly nice way to
connect to other databases via this
interface called the Postgres farm data
wrapper which basically exposes to one
database what looks like a table that's
actually a remote table connected via
RPC and so what that means is I could
actually I described a relational table
in your same database that relational
table could in fact be in a remote
database other than time scale and if
that could be joining across that via
the Postgres fgw interface I don't
remember the status of FTW connects to
Oracle and Sybase somebody else in this
room might can you run on Amazon RDS
version of Postgres so not yet we on our
website this is a request we often get
we are talking with them this is mostly
a function of actually RDS basically
whitelisting yes we are working with
with Amazon to do this and we on our
website you'll you'll see a in github
you'll see a link to the right person to
contact to push them along but we expect
it to happen in in months but you could
of course deploy on ec2 and we give you
know we have docker images and installs
and rpms and have other way you want to
install have you have you discovered any
fundamental problems with the poster
architecture the
makes your work difficult um I don't
think fundamental problems so Postgres
is one of the things will we take
advantage of so if you think about
extensibility of database like Postgres
um
Postgres extensibility in some sense is
the front end you could modify the query
plan or you can modify the execution
engine you're tying to all that you
could do what we did kind of change the
way that inserts and queries are handled
my sequel takes for example the very
different approach my sequel has a
constant front-end allows you to have a
different storage engine so typically
that's like I know DB or my Azzam but
you could also plug in your own storage
engine so these two trade-offs have pros
and cons um the reason we actually
particularly like post presses is that
we basically you know the thing that
takes five eight years to get mature is
the lowest level of data storage and
your use of you know right ahead logging
and backups and recovering everything
that makes the corner case is really
hard and for that because we've kind of
carefully designed ourselves to some of
this is an engineering challenge and how
do you bring all these advantages while
constraining yourself to some of the
ways that Postgres operates internally
um that has both obviously sometimes
required us to do certain things from an
engineering point of view on the flip
side we've dealt that be really
important so we don't have to rewrite
the storage engine and then you know
worry about an off by one error makes
your data not recoverable I think so far
we've only had one customer who went
silent or one user went silent for a
week and then they came back and said oh
I thought it was you had data corruption
and then turned out to be my vSphere
disks that had the corruption you were
you guys were okay
so so I think that has been a particular
importance of ours on the flip side is
if we allowed ourselves to arbitrarily
change our low-level storage model
there's other optimizations storage
optimizations we could do well that's
the decision we made so far
[Music]